the thing that soothes me and puts me to
bed at night is Kitchen Nightmares I
don't know what it is about Gordon
Ramsay screaming at people just makes me
that's literally what happens love you
Gordon hey everyone this is Madison Beer
and these are my favorite
[Music]
snacks yay okay this is an important one
this is arguably maybe the most
important pivotal one for me chocolate
chip original recipe they're not mini
cookies but they are mini cookies I'm so
happy that we were able to find these
and bring these here so my dad grew up
eating these these are like I can't open
it come on man don't embarrass me like
this I like don't know how to open boxes
this is like the
humiliating hi okay here are the cookies
they are the best cookies on Earth if
you've never tried one I highly suggest
you go to your nearest grocery store
store hopefully they have them they're
always soft no matter what and they're
amazing I wasn't sure if these were like
a New York specific thing or if they had
them in California I've actually ordered
them I think off Amazon a few times I
don't know if they have them everywhere
but I think they don't these are just
like a New York classic unfortunately my
Long Island accent is no longer with us
but if I speak to my dad or my grandma
or I go home for more than a week it
comes right on out these have been in my
house since I was born shout out to
Robert beer
okay
boom Chester fries these to be honest
with you are super important because
they were the introductory snack to
enjoying spicy things I like want to
pull this mic down so I can do ASMR
Fe I swear the first time I had these
was maybe on my first tour I think
someone gave them to me cuz I always
talk about how I really like I don't
know the word to describe it but just
things that are satisfying to eat I
don't know if anyone's going to
understand what I mean but these feel
satisfying like you can almost put one
of these in your mouth and it'll like
melt and I think one of my fans was like
you got to try Chester fries they're so
satisfying to eat so bizarre but she was
right and now I like spicy food I can't
really push it to the Limit but I'm like
willing to try anything so if you ever
see me on hot ones it'll be
interesting oh my gosh my catching
skills are on point today so let's have
a discussion about min
M&M something about them being in this
tube and being the size they are they're
just so addicting to a point that like I
don't know psychologically like what it
is like it takes everything in me to not
I don't know what movie it was was it
the hangover where Zack alakus like put
his whole mouth over a champagne glass
and then like went back and drank the
whole thing like that it takes
everything in me to not do that with
this and just send them all down the
hatch but I'm not going to do that
because I'm going to be an adult today
but like just holy there's
something again satisfying about these M
like what the crunch is just there it's
so
good thank you very much so here we have
our good old Oreo
McFlurry usually I get hot fudge on the
Oreo McFlurry but you know they are
disappointing a lot of the time because
I feel like most of the Oreo crumble is
on top and then once you get like
halfway done it's just vanilla ice cream
which nothing's wrong with vanilla ice
cream but like I would like an Oreo
experience through from top to bottom
and I don't get that
ever I think I love McDonald's for many
reasons I only really get fries and a
McFlurry which are consistent to me so I
think it's just like a consistency thing
oh this is the best day of my life thank
you
oh it just like will never let me down
like I'm a salty person and they are so
being salty so there's a
constant debate being from New York
living in Los Angeles what is better in
and out or Shake Shack I'm voting Shake
Shack all the way which argue with the
wall I don't care but McDonald's fries
Trump
all Cool Ranch Doritos yes these are the
best in the
world these are my number one honestly
in this whole tier Cool Ranch Doritos
are my number one I also always go for
the ones that have I don't know if I'm
like doing Vlog style I don't know if
you can see this but there's a lot of
seasoning on this one these are the ones
to go for you know I hate the nacho
cheese Doritos so it's not like an
overall like I'm a Doritos person these
are so good I was not always a ranch
person growing up I actually was like
slightly afraid of it thought it was
just disgusting my brother has always
loved Ranch he's always been like a
honey mustard and Ranch person and I've
been like a strictly ketchup person and
then in recent years I think it was also
McDonald's McDonald's McNuggets
converted me to be a ranch lover like
it's just the only pairing that's right
again argue with the
wall this is Grill
dinner I eat this every day no matter
what like at some point throughout my
day this is being consumed everyone
always is like what's on your Rider and
if you don't know what that is it's just
basically when you go places what snacks
people should provide you with this is
what I get let's start with A Little
Cucumber I don't know how people feel at
home about Sabra hummus but I
love
it
I could eat this all day so I do love
food I do love snacks and I love it so
much that the thing that soothes me and
puts me to bed at night is Kitchen
Nightmares I don't know what it is about
Gordon Ramsay screaming at people and
people fighting that just makes me
that's literally what happens he's just
so real in a world of such fakeness he's
so real I've seen every episode of
Kitchen Nightmares by the way and there
are a lot of episodes love you
[Music]
Gordon
all right guys thank you so much for
watching me talk about my very favorite
snacks this was so much fun and make
sure to listen to my new album sounds
between songs and catch me on tour I
start in February love
[Music]
you